a rewind option a variety of background  frames and screen savers using your own  gameplay are just three features the  SNES classic has that the NES classic  does not we got our hands on the hotly  anticipated SNES classic console and  took some time to play around with the  user interface and a couple games and  yes we did get some time with Star Fox 2  and we'll have a dedicated video for it  up shortly in the meantime why not give  us a like and subscribe to our YouTube  channel for more SNES classic news and  be sure to let us know in the comments  below what SNES classic game you're most  excited about thanks for watching  [Music]  [Music]  you  Oh  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]